by bipolar is a funny thing bipolar is a
terrible name for bipolar should it be
called it's a terrible name
unipolar unipolar it should be called
unipolar everybody else is
bipolar so if normal healthy people have
an experience throughout the day right
they're um they're coming home from work
they had a decent day at work they work
hard they feel accomplished at driving
home somebody cuts them off in traffic
real bad gives them the finger don't
even understand why I'm going to speed
limit right they feel put off and
they're like how I how dare they like
that's so rude people in LA are so rude
they have this feeling that's like
negative towards that experience and
maybe you know opens up feelings of like
insecurity or rage or whatever but
they're still sort of in that place
where they're like but I'm going home oh
well I can shake it off and I'm gonna
they're existing in two places at once
they can exist most people can exist in
two places at once like if [__] happens
there's still some part part of
themselves that's
okay with
bipolar you you can I personally cannot
experience two thing two states at once
it is one of the most intense versions
of that experience that you can possibly
imagine so if most people have 99 keys
on the keyboard and the lows are real
low and the highs are real high and they
can enjoy all those right and we can
sort of play in that range for me it is
extends as far as the IE can see deep
into the Horizon where it curves and
wraps around the edge of the Earth right
those keys still go some of those are so
deep that it's impossible to pull
yourself out of and you need help from a
team of people you need medication right
but I can't possibly experience those
extremes and also do what people tell
you to do go they go but just think
about all the things you have to be
grateful for play this key up here just
play that key let it pull you out no
dude there's no just playing that key
until life stops hammering That Base
tone for me I can't come out of it and
and there are times when I have this
kind of out-of- Body Experience when I
go
I I should let go of this feeling
like I have to let go of this feeling my
family needs me I need to be present
with my family there's got to be a way
out it's like I'm talking to myself
going like please and just won't dude
that is bipolar that's bipolar it's
unipolar it's you are going to
experience immediately the most intense
version of whatever your experien is and
it's it's authentic and there's no lying
about it it's so complex and deep those
feelings that um I can't act like I I'm
not feeling it and so that's really hard
for people and it's really hard for my
family because like if I'm upset because
of my kid the other day Okay so I've got
three boys they're 11 nine and seven
uh my seven-year-old is just a few days
behind me his birthday so he's about to
be
eight they're very sweet boys I'm so
grateful for them um they're wonderful
young men but they were mad at me
because I told them to go to bed and put
their stuff away the stuff that they
were doing and my littlest said f you
dad I I had had quite a day because I
was out in the countryside for work at a
place with no Wi-Fi and I had press
stuff I was talking to I was talking to
associate press and I was talking about
Washington Post all these things that
were supposed to be on camera these
interviews and I couldn't get a signal
dude and it was so frustrating so I'm
dealing with that and then my kid tells
me to f off because I asked him to go to
bed and I like lose my mind right and I
can't pull myself out of that place to
go like he's just a kid I I experienced
the feeling of a kid telling me to f off
and that feeling took over and there was
nothing else for like an hour and I it
it took me like an hour to finally kind
of like take it off dude it's [__]
the worst it is [__] the worst I
would give anything I would give
anything to not be bipolar but yet it's
also the fuel to what I do in my craft I
can experience things as a character
because I can tap into such wide ranging
emotions so deeply and authentically so
fast it's what makes things like reach
are interesting for you to watch so it's
a blessing and a massive [__] curse
dude I give anything to not be bipolar
hey guys I'm doing another live podcast
downtown LA at the Regent Theater and my
special guest for January 24th is
Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad Jessica
Jones this is going to be a soldout
event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael rosenbom with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so
excited